كل شيء في حينه لم يخبرهم احد متى موعد
الهجوم المضاد الذي تتوعد به قيادتهم صحيح
ان القياده الاوكرانيه شككت اخيرا في
القدره على التنفيذ شرقا او جنوبا في
الوقت الحالي غير ان الدعم الغربي الجديد
الذي حركته احدث استغاثه الرئيس زيلينسكي
ربما عجل به
ها هم الامريكيون يتعهدون بمواصله دعم
اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر قد يكون لواشنطن
هنا حساباتها الخاصه فوزير الدفاع تحدث
امام لجنه القوات المسلحه في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي عن سعي روسيا كما قال للسيطره
على البحر الاسود برمته وحرمان شركاء
واشنطن من الوصول اليه وبشان سير المعارك
يشير اوستن في تقريره الى ان روسيا
استنفذوا خزينتهم من العربات المدرعه بشكل
لم يكن متخيل مما دفعهم للجوء الى
الدبابات كبديل على الارض
لاعتبارات مشابهه سرع بقيه شركائ كييف
وتيره امدادها بالثقيل والفعال من الاسلحه
تتعزز اذا جبهات القتال بالدبابات
والمدرعات مع استمرار توريد السلاح وذاك
في ظل التقدم الروسي الاخير لا سيما على
الجبهه الشرقيه يؤكد وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوريكسي ريزني
معدات الجديده ستعزز الوحدات القتاليه
الاوكرانيه وان بلا له ستحرر جميع المدن
الاوكرانيه حسب تعبيره دبابات من البرتغال
ودبابات بريطانيه من طراز تشالنجر 2
ومدرعات امريكيه بالاضافه الى دبابات
ومركبات مشاه قتاليه المانيه من طراز
مارجر كلها بات تحت تصرف القوات
الاوكرانيه لا يروق الامر لموسكو التي
التفتت حصرا نحو برلين اذ اتهمها الكرملين
بزياده مستوى الخراطها في الصراع من خلال
المشاركه في تسليح كييف
لكن هل افلح تدفق السلاح الغربي في قلب
معادله السيطره في الميدان في جبهه الشرق
اللاهبه تواصل قوات فاجنر بحسب مصادر
روسيه شن عملياتها الهجوميه في المناطق
الواقعه شمال وجنوب مدينه بخموت بل وتتقدم
اكثر نحو مركز المدينه من الاتجاهين كما
ان قياده المواليه لروسيا اعلنت سيطره
قواتها على المنطقه الصناعيه
يضع كل ذلك مزيدا من الضغط على خطط الرئيس
الاوكراني لاطلاق ما وصف بهجوم الربيع
المضاد
فلا يمكن تنفيذ الهجوم كما قال زيلينسكي
اخيرا بدون دبابات ومدفعيه وراجمات صواريخ
امريكيه لكن حتى مع توالي دفعه الدعم
العسكري يقر مسؤولون غربيون بان التدريب
والتخطيط سيستغرقان بعض الوقت